so let's now get from
strategy and approach
to tactics
i got a really interesting email from
eric and colleen i think eric and
colleen are a couple that watch the show
and what eric and colleen wrote to me
about was the new democratic talking
points they seem to understand that
democrats have been falling to
republicans in many cases because
republicans much more effectively play
on fear and anger and that republican
talking points just naturally lend
themselves more to that and eric and
colleen wrote to me and said david you
know if you if we want to develop on the
left the same motivating fear and anger
that the republican party does we need
to change our messaging now eric and
colleen say
it doesn't even matter if our messaging
is true republicans lie all the time so
my question to you as i go through these
possible talking points that eric and
colleen suggested is how do we feel
about using talking points that we know
in some cases aren't true
is that taking the low road and we don't
want to do it but here are the new
talking points that eric and colleen
suggest should be repeated and repeated
and repeated in 2022 and 2024 on
abortion okay these are hypothetical
talking boys on abortion republicans
want to force you to have babies
and they will create a dangerous and
expensive black market of back alley
abortions
it's not really an exaggeration actually
it's using maybe hyperbolic language but
that one isn't wrong
on guns republicans will make it so easy
to get guns
that every criminal will be armed and
many of those will be armed with
semi-automatics
outfitted with high-capacity magazines
every criminal will be armed it's an
exaggeration but certainly the right
wants to make it really easy to get guns
on immigration republicans will shut
down the borders
women and children who are fleeing
violence are going to die at the border
of disease and starvation
or be sent back to death in their home
countries
hyperbolic but it plays on fear and it
plays on anger education republicans
will take control away from school
boards and implement a federal
government curriculum
it won't be based in science it won't be
based in accurate historical realities
it's going to be alternative facts lies
and christianity and they will impose it
on your children okay on the pandemic
republicans will not allow enforcement
of any safety measure they will ban mask
requirements they will ban vaccine
requirements and they are going to allow
this or a future pandemic to run rampant
they will allow
innocent americans to keep dying just to
avoid implementing any regulations
on deregulation republicans are going to
let poison and sewage pour into our
water systems they're going to build
more fossil fuel plants near your homes
and there will be more respiratory
disease and cancer as a result
on inequality
republicans will allow
wealth concentration to deepen and it
will destroy the middle class
that one seems just pretty pretty sober
actually
on taxes republicans will continue to
allow the rich and corporations to get
away with paying no taxes or close to it
the rich will get richer concentration
of power will become worse and it will
crush the middle class and lastly on
infrastructure the talking point
proposed by eric and colleen is our
infrastructure roads electrical grid
military educational system it will be
bankrupt thanks to
the rich in corporations paying almost
no taxes
this is more hyperbolic language than
democrats on the left tend to use
it's mostly accurate with some
exaggerations
how do you feel about it are these
do
democrats and does the left
need
to find talking points to generate that
exact same type of fear and anger that
the right does without and outlies and
if the answer is yes the left needs to
do that
does the left need to do it
without exaggeration and without
hyperbole or is it okay
to do it the way eric and colleen are
suggesting let me know your thoughts let
me know what talking points you think
the left should adopt you can find me on
twitter deepakman and we'll be back with
more right after this